Huge news in the web 2.0 world. This is Gary Vaynerchuck from Wine Library TV doing a 120 seconds about something besides wine.
Google buys Jaiku. Now, as Jaiku 2.0 dodgeball, and they're gonna do nothing with it or is Jaiku,
the Twitter-like app,
which I actually know the two founders and tasted a little wine with them in San Francisco not too long ago.
Is this a part of a much bigger scheme by Google to take the world by storm?
But really Facebook's world by storm on November 5th. And that's where I'm going. I'm going with the ladder.
I think November 5th is going to be a crossroads in the social networks world. I think Orkut 2.0,
which is where Google is going with this,
I think, is going to give Facebook a huge scare. Now Facebook with their amazing app
platform is doing some amazing things and growing like crazy. Getting very close to going public, because they're getting to those dollars
we're gonna have to report anyway so you know they're going in that direction. I think this Google
move is very curious and very serious. I think we're gonna see a totally different 2.0
platform out there, and I think
that Facebook has some real, real fears to see what Google does with this.
Orkut 2.0, with the use of Jaiku, their new addition, is going to be a very serious player, and
competitor to Facebook.
Ugh! It's so nice to talk about something besides wine. This is my 120 seconds of something else.